Hello, how are you, I greet you, Andrés González,
with his brief information for today,
Wednesday, April 21, if by chance you
drove through Maryland and Sheryl and
you notice enough police presence,
don't worry yesterday, yesterday was the first
day of emergency drills
carried out by the guard  nationwide
clark county fire department and law enforcement agencies
will continue training today tomorrow
around boulevard mall
near sunrise children's hospital
two nevada gambling properties
disclose
first quarter revenue today  in jim
wilson and las vegas sands will
hold meetings with their investors
both are expected to announce a plan to
restore the economy in the
hotel industry as the city
slowly returns to normal post
-pandemic
and while las vegas'  follow an
opening process the game resorts
is looking for employees
this technique if it does not organize fe
labor rias every wednesday the
sessions are from nine in the morning to one
in the afternoon at the company work center
near sánchez and you lose
many of the jobs they are
full time with benefits
and now we go to see the weather forecast
in the afternoon we will have a
sunny day with temperatures reaching
80 degrees rain is forecast for
next week after a weekend
events in the valley have a nice
day happen 3 gonzález and this was about
the news now in spanish
[Music]